in the UK we will deter more people from
coming here and make such routes
unviable
there has been a great deal of
misinformation about Rwanda
I visited Rwanda myself several years
ago
she's a state party to the 1951 United
Nations Refugee convention and the seven
core United Nations human rights
conventions
it is a safe and dynamic country with a
thriving economy
it has an excellent record of supporting
refugees and vulnerable migrants the UN
has used Rwanda for the relocation of
vulnerable migrants from Libya and this
was first funded by the European Union
many migrants including refugees have
already built excellent lives in Rwanda
and our partnership is a significant
investment in that country and further
strengthens our relationship
a myth still persists that the home
office permanent secretary opposed this
agreement
for the record he did not
nor did he assert that it is a definite
it is definitely poor value for money he
stated in his role as accounting officer
that the policies regular proper and
feasible but there is not currently
sufficient evidence to demonstrate value
for money
as he would be the first to agree it's
for ministers to take decisions having
received officials advice
and once the partnership is up and
running he will continue to monitor its
efficacy including value for money
now in June the first plane was ready to
relocate people to Rwanda our domestic
courts the high court the court of
appeal and the Supreme Court upheld our
right to send the flight
however
following an order by an out of hours
judge in the European Court of Human
Rights the flight was canceled
the European Court of human rights did
not rule that the policy or relocations
were unlawful but it prohibited the
removal of specific people
this was a without notice order and the
UK was not invited to make
representations to oppose it
Mr Speaker as a result we've been unable
to operate relocation flights pending
ongoing legal proceedings however we
have continued to prepare by issuing
notices of intent for those eligible for
relocation
and my right honorable friend the Prime
Minister recently outlined a
comprehensive new approach to Illegal
migration
now a judicial review was brought
against the Rwanda partnership by a
number of organizations and individual
Asylum Seekers
the first part of proceedings considered
a case
that the partnership is unlawful
part two argued that UK domestic
processes under the partnership were
unfair
and part three that the policy is
contrary to data protection laws
today the high court in a judgment
spanning over 130 pages law Justice
Lewis and Mr Justice Swift held that it
is indeed lawful for the government to
make arrangements for relocating Asylum
Seekers to Rwanda and for their Asylum
claims to be determined in Rwanda rather
than in the United Kingdom
the Court held further that the
relocation of Asylum Seekers to Rwanda
is consistent with the refugee
convention and with the statutory and
other legal obligations upon the
government including obligations imposed
by the Human Rights Act
Mr Speaker this judgment thoroughly
vindicates the Rwanda partnership
I spoke earlier today
with my Rwandan counterpart the Rwanda
Minister Vincent beruta and we both
confirmed our joint and steadfast
resolve to deliver this partnership at
scale as soon as possible
it's what the overwhelming majority of
the British people want to see happen
the sooner it is up and running the
sooner we will break the business model
of the evil gangs and bring an end to
these illegal unnecessary and unsafe
Channel Crossings
now that our courts have affirmed its
legality
I invite the opposition to get behind
this plan and I commend this statement
to the house I call the shutter Home
Secretary of equipment
thank you Mr Speaker the government has
failed to stop criminal gangs putting
lives at risk and proliferating along
our borders they failed to prosecute or
convict the gang members and if failed
to take basic Asylum decisions which are
down by 40 in the last six years
and instead of sorting those problems
out
they have put forward an unworkable
unethical extremely expensive Rwanda
plan which risks making trafficking
worse now the Home Secretary describes
today's court judgment as a Vindication
I have to wonder whether she has read it
because it sets out evidence of serious
problems in home office decision making
identifies significant financial costs
of this scheme and also very limited
numbers of people who will be covered
and certainly no evidence that this will
act as a deterrent or address the
serious problems that we face
the court concluded that the home office
decision making in each of the eight
cases considered was so flawed and
chaotic that those individual decisions
have had to be quashed literally cases
of mixing up evidence and names in
individual cases so they were making
decisions on the wrong people confusion
between teams in Glasgow and in Croydon
about who was deciding what and which
information should be shared evidence of
torture and trafficking not considered
and we know too that the home office
attempted to send heavily pregnant women
to Rwanda now this is a damning
indictment of the decision-making
process in the home office which we know
isn't working because 98 of the small
boat arrivaled in the last 12 months
have had no decision at all and where
government ministers seem to have
effectively decided they are so
incapable of getting a grip on the
Asylum system and taking Asylum
decisions effectively here in the UK
they want to pay a country halfway
across the world to take those decisions
for us now on the lawfulness of the
decision the court
did the Rwanda doesn't have a Island
processing capacity including
interpreters or legal support to take
these decisions but it's concluded the
agreement is still lawful because of two
key things that the number of people
Rwanda takes will be very limited and
there will be lots more money provided
by the UK government the Home Secretary
didn't tell us about any of those things
so can she now tell us how many people
does she expect to send to Rwanda next
year Rwanda said it can accommodate 200
people that is 0.5 percent of this
year's Channel Crossings the home office
itself has said there's no evidence it
will act as a deterrent and that it is
unenforceable and has a high risk of
fraud
secondly can she tell us the full cost
the court said there will be significant
additional funding provided the
government's already written Rwanda two
checks this year one for 120 million
pounds another this summer for 20
million pounds Millions more are
promised so how much more and how much
is this going to end up costing per
person because it looks like over a
million pounds per person at the moment
and third the court judgment says
there's no evidence the UK government
sought to investigate either the terms
of the Rwanda Israel agreement or the
way it had worked in practice why on
Earth not because that agreement was
abandoned with evidence that it had
increased trafficking and the activity
of criminal gangs convictions for people
smuggling have already dropped by 75
percent in the space of two years
convictions for people trafficking are
already pitifully low and a former Chief
Constable has warned the borders act
will make that worse time and again the
criminal the government is failing to
tackle the criminal gangs who are
driving this or to make them pay the
price so instead of this on workable
unethically unethical extortionally
expensive and deeply damaging policy the
government should be using this
investment to go after the gangs who are
putting lives at risk time and again all
they are doing is chasing headlines and
these are distractions damaging
distractions from the serious hard work
to tackle the gangs and sort out the
Asylum system the Home Secretary has
said that the conservatives are in Last
Chance Saloon it is their policies that
have put them there and that have let
the country down or was ramping up the
rhetoric never doing the serious hard
work or common sense Britain deserves
better than this Britain is better than
this
secretary
yeah
I'm very disappointed by the response
from the Shadow and secretary and more
actually concerned that she's actually
seeking to go behind what is a
legitimate decision by our independent
Judiciary set out rigorously
exhaustively thoroughly and suggests
that this is still an illegitimate
scheme we've seen through this judgment
that this is now lawful on several
grounds the Judgment looked at the
legislative Authority it looked very
closely about the claims as to whether
it breached article 3 of the European
convention on human rights the article
14 of the echr article 31 of the refugee
convention it looked very closely about
whether it was fair and uh or whether
access to Justice was respected it
looked very closely at other public law
grounds and on all of those claims
the home office one the court concluded
that it was lawful that it is lawful for
the government to make arrangements for
relocating Asylum Seekers to Rwanda and
for their Asylum claims to be determined
in Rwanda rather than the UK and that
judgment is a comprehensive analysis of
the reasons why
The Honorable Ryan relay does ask about
the eight individual cases and we have
we accept the Judgment of the court on
those individual cases we have already
taken steps to strengthen the case
working process including by revising
the information and the guidance given
to individuals during their assessment
for relocation but we've been clear
throughout that no one will be relocated
if it is unsafe for them and support is
offered to individuals throughout the
process to ensure that it is fair and
robust but Mr Speaker
if here is that labor have opposed
everyone
efforts to deter illegal migration
they've opposed the nationality and
borders act they've opposed life
sentences against people Smugglers
they've opposed the removal of foreign
National offenders including drug
dealers and rapists all they offer is
obstruction and criticism and
performative politics of opposition and
magical thinking because what do they
actually offer they say return to the
failed Dublin scheme no matter that it
was ineffective no better that the EU
doesn't want it they want safe and legal
Roots as the answer no matter that this
government has done more than any other
in recent history offering Sanctuary to
over 450
000 people by safe and legal groups no
matter that they can't actually Define
what routes they would stand up
themselves no matter that our capacity
is not unlimited Mr Speaker and that
there are over 100 million million
people displaced globally would labor
give them all a safe and legal route to
the UK Mr Speaker we cannot indulge in
fictions a fundamental reason that labor
can't articulate a plan is that they
can't be honest they can't be honest
with the British public about what they
really want the shadow Home Secretary
couldn't even decide if she would repeal
illegal entry even though she voted
against it their solution would be to
turn our crisis of illegal migration
into a crisis of legal migration open
borders by the back door unlimited safe
and legal routes is simply open borders
masquerading as humanitarianism Mr
Speaker last week the Prime Minister and
I announced our plan to tackle small
boats today the courts affirmed the
legality of a central peace in that plan
and tomorrow Mr Speaker labor still
won't have a plan
Sir William cash thank you Mr Speaker
although the High Court ruled that the
Rwanda policy is lawful there were as
has been said in that case only eight
Asylum claimants those cases have been
set aside by the court because that they
said at the same time in their ruling
that the circumstances of each claimant
had not been considered properly
the latest home office website fears
currently show that there are over 160
000 such individual cases outstanding
furthermore
as the Home Secretary in whom I have the
greatest confidence to each stated the
European Court Judge who issued the
injunction clearly did so without proper
consideration of the Rwanda policy and
such rulings do not command our respect
does my right honorable friend accept
that for all these reasons it becomes
more essential than ever to apply the
notwithstanding formula for the new
legislation which the Prime Minister has
now announced from mid-January which
must also distinguish in our own law
between genuine refugees and illegal
economic migrants not only in the
interests of saving life but also
preventing organized criminality but in
also asserting UK parliamentary
sovereignty overriding the European
convention and at the same time dealing
comprehensively with the current backlog
of those 160 000 outside outstanding
Asylum cases in that legislation
secretary
well my honorable friend makes a very
important point and what I want to be
clear about is that the European Court
of human rights did not rule on the
lawfulness of our policy it did not rule
that the policy or relocations were
unlawful but it did nonetheless prohibit
the removal of the individuals on the
14th of June flight fire interim and
injunctive relief we have a proud
tradition of Defending fundamental
rights in this country and this we will
always retain a robust approach to
protecting and preserving human rights
however that does not mean that we will
be uh we will have a migration system
that can be abused and exploited by
those who don't have legitimate claims
to be here and as the Prime Minister
announced last week we will be bringing
forward legislation to ensure that we
have a robust migration system and
secure borders
SNP spokesperson others some pool us
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker this is
a dark D indeed uh this with this
judgment and particularly when the home
of the Home Secretary come here comes
here to imply that having morals is
fanciful inverse Solomon of the refugee
Council has called this decision wrong
in this policy wrong in principle an
unworkable in practice and I am certain
that this will go to appeal as the
Charities and those involved uh in it
have stated the years in the SNP benches
we will never get behind this policy not
in our name and I remind people in this
house that slavery apartheid and marital
rape were all lawful at one time but
none of them were right the court found
that the home office failed considered
properly the circumstances of the eight
to challenge this policy so can I ask
the Home Secretary how exactly the
homesick how exactly she will intend to
approach these cases know what happens
to these uh these eight individuals what
happens also to the others who have
already been issued with notices of
intent what confidence can they have in
a system that didn't court that didn't
properly consider the cases of eight
people previously
the Home Secretary claims this will be a
deterrent well the attorneys also claim
that the hostile environment would be a
detent that the nationality and borders
act would be a deterrent and now the
Rwanda policy will be a deterrent none
of them are working because they fail to
recognize the very disparate
circumstances that drive people to come
here in the first place safe and legal
Roots will work and will prevent people
being losing their lives in the channel
the Home Secretary in her statement
talked about the trade into human cargo
and we all want to tackle the people
Smugglers that exploit people in the
most vulnerable of circumstances but I
ask her what else is this policy this
Rwanda policy but state-sponsored people
trafficking can I ask her how many
people are actually going to be removed
to Rwanda it's going to be a tiny tiny
proportion and therefore any deterrent
effect that they claim is not going to
be proper and can I ask her the total
cost lastly of this scheme as well
that's an unworkable scheming because
how much money has been spent already
how much of it has gone in the legal
case and how much would have been better
spent dealing with the catastrophic
backlogger cases that the Tories have
created secretary
well I'm afraid that The Honorable
lady's ideological Zeal is blinding
um and preventing her from taking a
rational approach I'm very proud of the
fact that we've welcomed 450
000 people through safe and legal routes
to this country since
2015 and I don't think anyone can claim
that we aren't forward-leaning on all of
this and I think that the honorable lady
in her party really needs to be honest
about their position with the British
people they stand for open borders and
uncontrolled migration Jacob Reese smog
Mr Deputy speaker
Parliament has legislated our courts
have ruled we are apparently stopped by
a Russian judge woken from a bar to
issue an injunction can can this stand
[Applause]
well
as always my writable friend makes a
very powerful point and uh I would just
say that
I uh the Prime Minister neither the
prime minister or I are deterred from
delivering upon this policy it's an
essential part of our wider plans to
break the business model to stop illegal
migration we have a legitimate basis for
it it has been upheld after being
rigorously tested in our courts we will
continue to move quickly in order to
honor the will of the British people
Jeremy corbyn thank you Mr Deputy
speaker the Home Secretary says that
Britain has a proud tradition of
supporting Asylum Seekers that is true
in part but it's not true under her
tenure
she is pursuing a vile policy which is
brutal towards the individual's
concerned and continually tells us that
it is illegal to seek Asylum it is not
it is clearly there in all International
conventions will she for once have a
sense of humanity towards people who are
desperate and are victims of Wars of
environmental change of Human Rights
abuse and exploited into boot cannotchin
just hold out a hand of friendship and
understanding towards these desperate
people rather than this brutal assertion
she's making today
the right honorable gentleman keeps
talking uh on a regular basis about safe
and legal Roots as being a means to an
end of illegal arrivals but the reality
is that our safe and legal routes
already have allowed 450 000 people to
come here since 2015. 300 000 in the
last year alone the highest number that
we've seen in several decades but that
needs to happen in conjunction with
deterrent policies if they are to have
any effect and if we are to stop
the practice of people taking lethal and
unlawful Journeys across the channel
jumping the queue undermining the
British people's generosity and breaking
the law Edward Lee
welcome it won't solve the problem not
just because of the relatively few
numbers that can be deported to Randa
but because each case must be fought
individually and human rights laws will
fight every single case individually
that is the problem
surely the only serious way we can deter
migration across a channel is to have
the legal right not just to process
people when they arrive on our Shores
but to arrest them and detain them until
their Asylum application is dealt with
now is there anything in the refugee
convention which stops US doing that if
there isn't why aren't we doing it and
if it's a human rights act that stops us
doing it can we not apply in our new
legislation for a notwithstanding Clause
to deal with that problem
well
um we this is exactly why the Prime
Minister announced last week and I and
the immigration Minister are working
intensively to prepare legislation which
will be introduced next year
um and that and it will uh deliver a
scheme along the lines of what he's just
described whereby if you come here
irregularly or illegally uh I.E on a
small boat uh putting yourself and
others at risk you will be detained and
you will be swiftly removed to a safe
third country or to Rwanda for your
Asylum claim to be processed Kevin Jones
the Home Secretary in a statement
confirmed that the permanent secret home
office had concerns about the cost and
that she overruled him now we've spent
140 million pounds so far not one single
individual is being removed when The
Honorable member for Corby was the
immigration Ministry he said that the
average cost of removing people would be
12 000 pounds Summit was not based in
any fact so she's so confident about the
scheme she took a decision to overall
the permanent secretary will she not
today publish all the costs of of this
scheme so that we can all take a view of
whether it is good a good use of
taxpayers or whether it's not just
simply we're fulfilling one of her weird
dreams
The Honorable gentleman needs to get his
facts right because actually the uh the
policy was the agreement was struck
between my predecessor the friend my
American friend the member for Witham
and the Rwandan government
um but I support the work that she did
and the achievements that she struck
which is that she uh that the agreement
it represents a long-term policy it's
expected to last for at least five years
and the cost and the payments will
depend on the number of people relocated
the timing of when that happens and the
outcomes of the individual cases of
course we've been held up by litigation
and once the litigation process comes to
an end we will move quickly to deliver
it and deliver value for money yeah
Natalie elfic
speaker
um I I am saddened that Following last
week's tragic events neither the shadow
at home secretary or the SMP labor front
uh sorry s p front bench are prepared to
actually say that people should not be
getting into these boats in the first
place they should be claiming refuge and
asylum in the one of the 149 convention
countries many of which they will have
gone through I I um I welcome today's
judgment um from the high cause I asked
my right honorable friend that isn't it
even better than Rwanda that people stay
safe on land in France and do not take
these Crossings in the first place
my honorable friend is absolutely right
people should not be making this journey
they should not be Crossing through
other safe countries and they shouldn't
be choosing to come to the United
Kingdom via these means and the sooner
that we are able to deliver a policy
that reflects that the better hello
crazy thank you Mr Deputy speaker the
courts have been
blanket approached the treatment of
refugees just as it would be wrong to
decide that everybody caught speeding
could never drive again what matters is
treating each case on its merits now
we've seen already how poorly this
government is treating children who are
here who are Refugee children
the Home Secretary talks about being
honest so let's finally have some honest
straight answers for avoidance of Doubt
will a Home Secretary confirm whether or
not she is intending to deport children
or those who are looking after children
who are here or refugees to Rwanda yes
or no will children be on those flights
ministers
we've been very clear that families are
not subject to the Rwandan policy but
the broader point is this there is a she
takes a different reading of the
Judgment than I do there's been an
extensive and exhaustive Analysis of the
legal claims brought against the
government and the court has been pretty
emphatic on the legality of the policy
it's concluded that the scheme is
compliant with our echr obligations and
with our Refugee obligations so John
whittingdale oh thank you Mr Deputy
speaker can I tell my writable friend
that two months ago I visited hope
hostel in Kigali where Not only was the
accommodation of a high standard but the
rwandans I spoke to express their hope
that those coming would in due course
obtain jobs and move out to their own
homes thus allowing more refugees to
come and take their place so does she
not agree that this policy is not just
lawful it is also humane
first refugees a real hope
absolutely and he is reiterating a point
which is extensively dealt with in the
body of the judgment and I referral
members and my members to that judgment
where there's a complete analysis of the
exact kind of support that people will
receive when they're in Rwanda the kind
of monitoring that will go on to ensure
that their welfare is safeguarded and
the track record that Rwanda has
demonstrated in supporting refugees from
the region in previous instances
Christine Jardine thank you very much Mr
Speaker it's frustrating to stand here
and listen to the Secretary of State
because none of us are denying that it's
a legal ruling but whether or not it is
lawful this plan is immoral and
effective and Incredibly costly for
taxpayers
instead of wasting taxpayers money
defending a policy through the courts
does the Secretary of State not agree
that the government should be focusing
on stopping these dangerous Crossings
and tackling the Smugglers and
trafficking by providing more safe and
legal routes and Sanctuary for refugees
rather than dealing with the problem
after people arrive here deal with it at
source so they are never put in the
position where they take the dangerous
Crossing across the channel
well as the justices make clear at the
beginning of their judgment they're not
opining on the politics or the morality
of the Rwanda scheme they are simply
opining on the lawfulness and that's why
I have huge confidence in the Judgment
that's just been handed down today but
if we're talking about the broader
issues I mean I gently disagree with the
honorable ladies you would imagine I
think what's actually unacceptable is
that her party is peddling a mistruth to
the British people it's saying that we
can have an unlimited and open borders
policy and we have unlimited capacity in
everybody's welcome unfortunately the
reality the reality is that is not the
case and we have to take a pragmatic
measured and compassionate approach to
our migration and that's what's sensible
and required by the British people Greg
Smith Deputy speaker Central to solving
the crisis of illegal migration is the
prevention of further loss of human life
in the English Channel so not only do I
welcome today's judgment but my right
humble friend's commitment in a
statement to deliver the Rwanda
partnership at scale and as soon as
possible but it is clear that there will
be continued continued legal challenges
to it either on an individual basis or
on a whole policy basis so can I push
the Home Secretary further on the point
made by my writable friend for stone
that the legislation coming in the new
year that I look forward to supporting
really must include and notwithstanding
Clause to ensure that we can prevent
that loss of further human life in the
channel
it's a good rape what what's essential
is that we introduce uh consider and
pass legislation that will be uh robust
and resilient and actually deliver Upon
Our stated political objectives that
will require an exhaustive analysis of
the legal methods but simply put we're
in the process we're in the sausage
machine as they would put it so it's not
a pretty sight but nothing is off the
table Antonio Mr Deputy speaker the Home
Secretary said over the weekend that she
is considering leaving the European
prevention and human rights in order to
prevent people claiming Asylum
is it possible Mr Deputy speaker to do
this without breaking our commitments in
the Belfast Good Friday agreement
[Music]
I think what's clear is that there are
evident challenges with the way in which
International conventions and agreements
relating to migration are working in the
21st century I think there are
legitimate questions that the
international level all nation states
are grappling with I've seen that
firsthand when I've spoken to my
counterparts at the Calais group or
other International Partners there is a
an unprecedented scale of illegal
migration there are is unprecedented
pressure on domestic resources and I
think looking at how we can forge a new
uh set of agreements to work better
together is definitely a reasonable
approach
so Desmond Swain were more safe and
legal roots to be made available
they would quickly be taken up
and the trade in small boats would then
continue unabated wouldn't it yes
yes
thank you very much indeed Mr Deputy
speaker could the Home Secretary clarify
for that oh [ __ ] if someone arrives on
the shores at Dover to claim asylum in
order to be able to join a child
spouse or an elderly parent here in the
United Kingdom right to family life
can she assure the house that that
individual would not
be put on a plane to Rwanda and
separated from their family for the rest
of their lives
the reality is that anybody arriving
here
irregularly will be eligible for
consideration we will it consider every
case on its individual merits we have
excluded families from the scheme but we
will also ensure that the uh the the
decisions are made on a lawful and
rational basis because
Mr Deputy speaker
the I very much welcome the ruling today
and and the comments of the Home
Secretary and it's quite clear from what
we're hearing from Members opposite that
there's a great Gulf between uh their
views and the the vast majority of the
British people overwhelmingly my
constituents will want to see the uh
Home Secretary and the prime minister's
proposals implemented as quickly as
possible in particular there is genuine
concern about the speed of uh processing
uh the many cases and although
additional staff are being taken on the
pitiful number of K of cases they're
dealing with on a weekly basis needs to
be dramatically improved come our right
honorable friend assure me that action
is being taken to ensure that happens
secretary processing Asylum claims is
one core element of solving the
challenge more broadly and that's why
it's right that we're increasing the
number of caseworkers increasing their
specialism streamlining the process
because ultimately we want to Bear Down
on the numbers of people waiting for a
decision from the home office Caroline
Lucas thank you Mr Deputy speaker the
Home Secretary says she's taking a
deterrent approach but it's playing that
today's judgment cannot and will not
function as a so-called deterrent since
the whole point of this vile policy of
expelling Asylum Seekers Rwanda is that
expulsion was supposed to happen
automatically and rapidly for anyone
without a prior permission to come here
via a refugee scheme but today's high
court judgment found that each and every
individual case must be assessed first
so there'll be nothing automatic about
it and under this government there'll be
nothing rapid about it either so will
she put a permanent end to this useless
cruelty provide safe and legal roots and
Ensure such Roots actually function
because the one from Afghanistan
currently doesn't and will she stop
saying that this policy has the support
of the British people there is a recent
poll from yougov that shows that just 10
actually support this the British people
are better than this vile British
government
can secretary well I think that the
reality is that we are supported in
taking control over our borders that was
reflected in the 2016 referendum
endorsed in the 2019 referendum election
and and we have made clear that we will
do whatever it takes to ensure we get uh
uh we make progress on stopping illegal
migration we uh bring an end to people
taking this lethal journey and
ultimately we restore Integrity to our
immigration system
I welcome the Judgment today I find it
deeply frustrating there that just one
isolated judge can delay this process
for around six or seven months
um Google Home Secretary give me some
sense of the time scales you've had
today's judgment when are the first
flight's going to take off that is what
we all want to see and that's where my
constitutions will begin to rest easy
when they can see those flights taken up
and also finally we will probably have
to strike agreements with other
countries
um Can the homosexual assure me that
when we do strike Community other
countries they are not delayed in the
same way that this one has been delayed
and we don't go through exactly the same
motions again which take oh so long
yeah
well um it's he he's he's right that you
know we've always maintained that this
policy is lawful and today the court has
upheld that we know that there are
further legal challenges that are
possible and we will continue to
vigorously defend this in the courts
going forward but uh once the litigation
process has come to an end we will move
swiftly to be in a position to
operationalize it and deliver on our
promise drawn a cherry
speaker can I just caution the Home
Secretary gently against getting too
overexcited about our decision at first
instance and often important
constitutional decisions at first
incidents are overturned on appeal think
of example for recently uh when uh the
last prime minister what one unlawfully
paroled Parliament and I think an appeal
here is inevitable and in the meantime
removals to Rwanda can't take place
because of the interim measures issued
by the European Court of Human Rights
and maybe she'd like to explain to some
of her backbenchers the concept of an
interim order issued by a judge sitting
alone to preserve the status quo which
happens I believe in English law
regularly by way of injunction but my
question to her is this she seems to be
implying that she will obtemper the
order of the European Court of human
rights which of course was issued under
article 34 of the convention which the
United Kingdom is bound by but I know
she's not a great fan of the convention
and a lot of her back benches are asking
her about this notwithstanding Clause so
can I ask her this is it her intention
to domestically legislate her way out of
our International treaty obligations
well um it's not appropriate for me to
speculate on the response of the
claimants or whether there will be any
uh subsequent appeals following today's
judgment we welcome today's findings and
we will vigorously defend any Appeal on
the substantive matters of the
lawfulness of the policy
we've been clear that in designing and
introducing our legislation next year we
will have to ensure that it is
sufficiently robust to uh to to promote
a scheme that uh that means that if you
are arriving here illegally you will be
detained and you'll be swiftly removed
to a safe country for your Asylum plane
to be processed Philip hollabayne
Kettering welcome the high court
judgment and want to see the true
location flights to Rwanda take off as
soon as possible they will be very
concerned to hear today that this could
be subject to further judicial delay
could the Home Secretary outline to my
constituents in Kettering how long she
anticipates that judicial delay will be
and when can I tell my constituents that
the flights will take off
well the reality of litigation is that
there are always that there are appeal
rights there is a hearing on the 16th of
January at which the claimants and the
home office will make representations
regarding any applications to appeal the
court will decide the next steps if any
in UK litigation we are currently
considering the UK's the home office's
position
um with my legal team so it wouldn't be
appropriate for me to discuss what our
strategy is in the meantime but uh yes
there is a hearing on the 16th of
January to consider appeal applications
uh tries very hard to find the way
forward on a solution
we're saying I absolutely acknowledge
and defer to the high court ruling I say
this with great respect to the right
honorable living what is clear is that
we have a duty of care and I believe
along with many others in this nation in
this house today and I said at this
house do not believe that this scheme
fulfills our moral obligation so can the
Secretary of State again confirm that
should another way of dealing with the
current situation is identified better
regulation in this channel uh better
processors in France more acceptable or
extra ways of migration for those who
wish to and there will be others that
this will be given consideration as I do
believe that there has to be a more
compassionate approach that can be taken
yeah yeah
you can uh involve the multifaceted
approach and that's why we are working
very closely with the French and I was
very pleased to strike an agreement last
month with my French counterpal to
bolster our cooperation on the channel
uh information and intelligence sharing
for the first time ever UK border Force
officials working hand in hand with our
French counterpart counterparts in
France that's why I've also worked
closely with other interior ministers
from European nations on the similar
issue that's why we need to work on our
Asylum backlog that's why we need to
introduce legislation the Rwanda scheme
is one element of a very
multi-dimensional program and I think we
need all elements to work in tandem
Jack barrettson thank you it's a deputy
speaker as Home Secretary knows
Stoke-on-Trent has already done more
than all fair share and this has put
huge pressure on our local public
services so would my right home friend
agree that it's really important that we
get on now with delivering this policy
and get on with those flights as soon as
possible
well I pay tribute to him and his Stoke
parliamentary colleagues the local
authorities and all of those involved in
supporting Asylum seekers in Stoke and I
and I know that there is a high number
of people currently accommodated uh in
in his uh in his area it is therefore
vital that we stop people coming in the
first place and delivering the Rwanda
partnership is key to making that happen
um
Kaiser
an empty speaker is the super rich in
those unluxury Yachts not small boats
that people should be scared of Asylum
Seekers are people just like us they
have hopes dreams and aspirations less
policy could be legally sound but it's
immoral and a waste of taxpayers money
this crew government should be ashamed
of themselves the Home Secretary in our
statement says less judgment thoroughly
medicates the Rwanda partnership and
it's what the overwhelmingly majority of
the British people want to see happen of
course the Rwanda partnership wasn't in
the Tory Manifesto so can she evidence
less support that people across all four
nations what marijuana deal because
Scotland certainly doesn't in Scotland
will continue to reject these xenophobic
policies
[Music]
well
the reality is is that actually uh
stopping people taking the journey in
the first place is the compassionate and
pragmatic approach it delivers for the
British people but it also sends a
message to those people Smugglers human
traffickers and those who are
deliberately taking the journey to come
here for illegitimate means not to do so
that's a sensible approach going forward
Mr Deputy speaker um could I welcome the
Judgment today that confirms the
government's policy is legal and will be
a step forward to implementing what the
Prime Minister said last week the home
secretaries right that we need to
destroy the break the business model the
people Smugglers does she agree with me
that it's not enough just to go after
the supply even though those people are
immoral and parasitic we need to destroy
the demand for these Journeys in the
first place and the way we'll achieve
that is by making clear that those that
come by boat won't be allowed to stay in
this country that's what worked in
Australia that's what will work here
he's absolutely right and I've met with
Australian officials who were involved
in the design of their Sovereign borders
program and they say uh very much that
that actually once they were able to
remove a legal entrance to Papua New
Guinea or nauru they saw a dramatic
change in the numbers of people
attempting the journey in the first
place and that's the model upon which
arawanda scheme is based
if every country took this government's
approaches Rwanda approach the countries
who already host the overwhelming
majority of refugees and Jordans the
labor known as the Pakistan's the
ugandans of this world the first
countries they would instead be required
to host all of them while wealthy
Western countries like the United
Kingdom could pick and choose if and
when they wanted to help out what this
government is arguing for is avert the
end to the International System of
refugee protection is it not
I really
um disagree with the moral High Ground
that my honorable friend seems to be
taking here in light of Scotland's
poultry record in taking Asylum Seekers
they've refused to take anybody who's
come here on a small boat and that Mr
Speaker is unacceptable
thank you Mr Deputy speaker I welcome
the statement today in the Judgment but
will the Secretary of State confirm to
this house that she will continue to use
every tool in her power to stop these
bolts as you can see the opposition and
the will be the human rights those who
will try and stop what the good work
that the secretary of state is doing
because the people of Doncaster are
tired of being taken advantage of by
these illegal immigrants so will she
confirm to the house that she will
continue to use everything every Power
that she has
well my uncle friend not only speaks to
the people of Doncaster but he speaks
for the people of Britain uh in his
question there and expressing the
sentiment that the British people are
tired and they want this problem to be
fixed it's only this government that's
going to do it
yeah the Grady
thank you Mr Deputy speaker how many of
the people who were pulled from the
channel last week does she think should
be sent to wonder
what they wouldn't be well uh the
incident last week was tragic
people died
precious human lives were lost
people had been exploited and took a
journey which was unlawful and lethal
and in the end tragic that's what we
want to bring to an end
thank you Mr Deputy speaker the court
found that the home office would have to
consider Asylum Seacoast particular
circumstances before deporting them to
Rwanda there's a Home Secretary
acknowledged that this defeats the
purpose of this scheme where the
original intent was to have applications
assessed in Rwanda under Rwandan law and
the sexual to reconsider this is
interesting well the the judgment is
very clear that our Arrangement which
means that people will be relocated to
Rwanda so their Asylum claims to be
processed and then they will be
resettled uh there that that's been
found to be lawful and there's been an
extensive analysis of all the potential
legal claims that could render that
unlawful and the home office has won
I'll see the end of that stamina I'd
like to thank the Home Secretary for her
statement today and responding to
questions for over 50 minutes and we're
now moving on to the next statement
which is on the convention on
biodiversity cop 15 outcomes and I
called Therese copy
thank you Mr Deputy speaker with your
permission I'd like to update the house
on the outcome of cop15 of the
convention biodiversity which was held
in Montreal and from which I've just
returned
too long Nature has been overlooked the
Cinderella of the story but flora and
fauna are important in and of themselves
nature is both the essential foundation
and a powerful engine for our economies
and helping nature recover is one of the
most effective cost-effective ways we
can tackle so many challenges including
the calls as an impacts of climate
change first Hunger and health and
bolstering piece and prosperity
early this morning the world came
together to secure the strong ambitious
Global framework we need to catalyze a
decade of environmental action on the
scale of the Paris agreement as for
climate putting nature firmly on the map
the agreement includes Global targets to
protect at least 30 percent of the
world's land and at least 30 percent of
the global ocean by 2030 and to see
natural systems restored populations of
species recovering and extinctions
halted
it includes reporting in review
mechanisms that will hold all of us to
account for making timely progress on
bringing our promises to life and it
includes commitments on digital sequence
information to make sure communities in
nature-rich countries feel the benefit
of sharing the solutions that we know
their flora and fauna can provide
behind the scenes over very over many
months now we've been working with
Ecuador Gabon and the Maldives to
develop the credible 10-point plan for
financing biodiversity during this
decade that played a critical role in
getting this agreement over the line by
giving nature-rich countries confidence
in our Collective willingness and
ability to secure the investment needed
to protect natural wonders on which
their people and in many cases the whole
world depends and on the back of those
efforts public private and philanthropic
philanthropic donors committed billions
of dollars of new investment in nature
the agreement itself includes
commitments to create a new
international fund for nature to
increase investment in nature from all
sources to 30 billion dollars a year by
2030 and to accelerate the vital shifts
that are already underway to make sure
that our economies underpin our survival
and our success
and I want to thank our team of
ministers and pay tribute to all our UK
civil servants from across government as
well as world-leaching scientists from a
range of British institutions including
Kew Gardens and jncc
Mr Deputy speaker we've been on this
journey since the last CBD cop 14 that I
attended in Egypt in 2018 and in
meetings with delegations from around
the world time and again we heard praise
for the way our world-class UK
negotiators helped to broker this
agreement
we know from experience here in the UK
that when we set ambitious targets what
we see is an acceleration of action to
meet them across government sectors and
communities and that is why we have
worked so hard to secure these Global
targets and just before I set off for
Canada I announced that we have taken
the next steps towards leaving the
environment in a better State than we
founded we're putting in a set of new
stretching domestic targets into UK law
under the environmental act on air water
and waste as well as nature Land and Sea
to improve the state of the environment
in our country
these targets will be challenging to
meet but they are achievable and the
global coalitions of ambition that we
have been leading co-leading and
supporting will now shift towards
supporting implementation of the new
international nature agreement as well
to speak Mr Deputy speaker the UK is
committed to playing our part now and in
the months and years ahead and while no
country can solve this alone if we work
together to make this a decade of action
we stand not just to avoid the worst
impacts but by securing the abundance
diversity and connectivity of life on
Earth to build a better future for every
generation to come and I commend the
statement to the house so Bell
yeah thank you Miss Deputy speaker I
thank the Secretary of State for
advanced sight of her statement the
agreement signed a Montreal this morning
protect 30 of the planet for nature and
restore thirty percent of the planetary
grade ecosystems is welcome news that we
are to protect a minimum 30 of land and
30 of our seas is a benchmark we must
adhere to to avoid ecosystem collapse I
was glad to be part of the UK's
delegation to cop15 the Secretary of
State used to spot the global station
announced UK's environmental targets the
ones were where she missed her own
legally binding deadline in October I
know Mr Speaker the secretary didn't
announce the blade targets to the house
first in the proper way and I think that
speaks volumes we still have an oral
statement on those targets it's quite
astonishing then and after all of the
warm Worlds the government's own targets
do not include a 30 goal protecting
nature the Central State compared nature
to Cinderella Mr Speaker that's the case
and the members for Camborne redruth
North East Hampshire and Suffolk Coastal
must be the cruel stepsisters of the
neglect her during their time in charge
the government also failed to include
overall measures for water quality and
protected sites in their targets the
reality of the sector States watered
down targets means our country and our
communities will face even more toxic
air and more sewage dumping for longer
cynics view might be the government is
happy to commit to non-legally binding
Targets in Montreal while shirking any
real responsibility at home ambitious
environmental leadership means at the
very least ensuring clean air clean
water and access to Nature it doesn't
matter how the government tried to dress
it up their targets do not go anywhere
near far enough and it's our community
will suffer as a result rivers in
England are used as open sewers not one
is in a healthy condition only 14 meet
good ecological standards with no
overall water quality targets the
conservatives can continue to allow raw
sewage to flow into our natural
environment hundreds of thousands of
times a year how does that fit with our
Montreal commitments only labor has a
proper plan to clean up our waterways we
introduce mandatory monitoring with
automatic fines hold water bosses
personally accountable sewage pollution
give Regulators the power to properly
enforce the rules one in five people in
the UK with respiratory conditions such
as asthma and COPD which are worsened by
breathing toxic air we know the special
dangerous children and vulnerable adults
any concern are the unambitious targets
for air quality set out by the
government labor committee tackling this
Health crisis once and for all with a
Clean Air Act giving the right to
breathe clean air monitoring and tough
new duties of ministers to make sure who
clean air guidelines are kept of the 20
U.N biodiversity targets agreed to in
2010 the UK has missed 17 17 missteps
speaker when it comes to environment the
government constantly make the wrong
choices delay vital action duct the
Urgent challenges failure to deliver on
environment targets home show their
promise that cop 15 mean very little the
secretary state's own colleague at cop
the Lord Goldsmith described the UK is
one of the most nature depleted on the
planet the environment Atmos Target on
speech abundance which they were forced
to conceive opposition amendments
promised only to Halt the decline speech
by 2030. how does that now sit with our
Montreal commitments misadep speakers
clear from secretary States watered down
environmental is conservative government
have given up on governing
well Mr Speaker never heard such rubbish
in the opposition it's all really quite
sad about this for start let's just get
it clear The Honorable member was uh it
was good that he went to Montreal but he
was not a member of the UK government's
delegation but I'm glad that he went
anyway as did other members and at the
first opportunity after getting
clearance to the targets I did inform
Parliament and a written ministerial
statement was laid in the Lords on
Friday before I made a short
announcement into uh into uh into well I
was in Montreal so in terms of
um
I'm very clear Mr Deputy speaker
genuinely this agreement would not have
been as strong if it not been for the
efforts of the UK government even this
morning in the dark hours in Montreal
the text was reopened at our insistence
to make sure that the depletion of
nature was included in the text of what
was agreed at the same time we have been
working tirelessly day in day out during
this negotiation to make sure that we
did secure finances because I'm very
conscious of many nature Rich around
countries around the world need that
financial support in order to make sure
that nature is restored and in terms of
what we're planning to do here in the UK
Mr Deputy speaker frankly Nature has
been depleted ever since frankly the
Industrial Revolution that has recently
been more recognized that is why it is
this government that put in place the
environment act by the way that builds
on a number of environment acts which
previous conservative administrations
have put into place recognizing the
importance of legislation but also
delivery in terms of that The Honorable
gentleman refers to the air quality
Target the only reason why we've kept
what we consulted on over 10 micrograms
per meter cube for pm2